Mi madre nunca dejó de trabajar para mí,
desde mi nacimiento hasta el nacimiento de mi hijo.
Ella ya sabía lo que estaba empezando a nombrar.
Ese amor es más que una avalancha de sentimientos
eso nos sucede si tenemos suerte.
El amor es trabajo dulce.
Feroz.
Sangriento.
Imperfecto.
Vivificante.
Una elección que hacemos una y otra vez.
Soy activista por los derechos civiles estadounidenses
que ha trabajado con comunidades de color desde el 11 de septiembre,
he luchado contra políticas injustas del estado y actos de odio en la calle.
Y en nuestros momentos más dolorosos,
frente al fuego de la injusticia,
he visto entregar actos de amor.
Mi vida en la lucha contra el odio en EE. UU. ha sido un estudio
en lo que he llegado a llamar amor revolucionario.
El amor revolucionario es la elección para entrar en trabajo de parto
para otros que no se parecen a nosotros,
para nuestros oponentes que nos lastiman
y para nosotros mismos.
En esta era de enorme ira,
cuando los incendios arden a nuestro alrededor,
creo que el amor revolucionario es la llamada en nuestro tiempo.
Si sienten vergüenza ajena cuando alguien dice: "El amor es la respuesta..."
Yo también.
(Risas)
Soy abogada.
(Risaa)
Así que déjenme mostrarles cómo llegué a ver el amor
como una fuerza para la justicia social a través de tres lecciones.
Mi primer encuentro con el odio fue en el patio de la escuela.
Yo era una niña pequeña que vivía en California,
donde mi familia ha vivido y cultivado durante un siglo.
Cuando me dijeron que iría al infierno por no ser cristiana,
llamándome "perro negro" por no ser blanca,
corrí a los brazos de mi abuelo.
Papa Ji me secó las lágrimas,
me dijo las palabras de Guru Nanak,
el fundador de la fe sikh.
"No veo extraño", dijo Nanak.
"No veo enemigo".
Mi abuelo me enseñó
que podría elegir ver todas las caras que encuentro
y preguntarme por ellas.
Y si pregunto por ellos,
escucharé sus historias incluso cuando sea difícil.
Me negaré a odiar a las personas incluso cuando me odien.
Incluso juraré protegerlos cuando estén en peligro.
Eso es lo que significa ser un sikh:
Sikh.
Para caminar el camino de un santo guerrero.
Él me contó la historia de la primera mujer guerrera sij,
Mai Bhago.
La historia dice que 40 soldados abandonaron su puesto
durante una gran batalla contra un imperio.
Regresaron a una aldea,
y esta mujer del pueblo se volvió hacia ellos y dijo:
"No abandonarán la pelea.
Volverán a la batalla,
y yo les guiaré".
Ella montó a caballo.
Ella se puso un turbante.
Y con la espada en la mano y fuego en sus ojos,
ella los condujo a donde nadie más lo haría.
Ella se convirtió en la única que estaba esperando.
"No abandones tu puesto, querida".
Mi abuelo me vio como una guerrera.
Yo era una niña con dos largas trenzas,
pero lo prometí.
Avance rápido, ya con 20 años,
mirando caer las Torres Gemelas,
el horror atrapado en mi garganta,
y luego una cara parpadea en la pantalla:
un hombre moreno con turbante y barba,
y veo que el nuevo enemigo de nuestra nación se parece a mi abuelo.
Y estos turbantes destinados a representar nuestro compromiso a servir
nos identifican como terroristas.
Y los sikhs se convirtieron en objetivos de odio,
junto a nuestros hermanos y hermanas musulmanes.
La primera persona asesinada en un crimen de odio tras el 11 de septiembre
fue un hombre sikh, de pie frente a su estación de servicio en Arizona.
Balbir Singh Sodhi era un amigo de la familia al que yo llamaba "tío",
asesinado por un hombre que se hacía llamar "patriota".
Él es el primero de muchos que han sido asesinados,
pero su historia,
nuestras historias apenas llegaron a las noticias de la noche.
No sabía qué hacer,
pero yo tenía una cámara,
me enfrenté al fuego.
Fui a ver a su viuda,
Joginder Kaur.
Lloré con ella y le pregunté:
"¿Qué le gustaría decirle a la gente de EE. UU.?"
Esperaba culpa.
Pero ella me miró y dijo:
"Diles, 'Gracias'.
3000 estadounidenses asistieron al funeral de mi esposo.
Ellos no me conocían,
pero lloraron conmigo.
Diles, 'Gracias' ".
Miles de personas se presentaron,
porque a diferencia de las noticias nacionales,
los medios locales le contaron la historia del tío Balbir.
Las historias pueden crear la maravilla
eso convierte a extraños en hermanas y hermanos.
Esta fue mi primera lección de amor revolucionario.
Que las historias pueden ayudarnos a no ver a nadie como extraño.
Y entonces,
mi cámara se convirtió en mi espada.
Mi título de abogada se convirtió en mi escudo.
Mi compañero de reparto se convirtió en mi esposo.
(Risas)
No esperaba eso.
Y nos convertimos en parte de una generación de defensores
trabajando con comunidades que enfrentan sus propios incendios.
Trabajé dentro de las cárceles supermax,
en las costas de Guantánamo,
en los sitios de tiroteos masivos,
cuando la sangre todavía estaba fresca en el suelo.
Y cada vez,
por 15 años,
con cada película, con cada demanda,
con cada campaña,
pensaba que estábamos haciendo que la nación fuera más segura
para la próxima generación.
Y luego nació mi hijo.
En un tiempo
cuando los crímenes de odio contra nuestras comunidades
están en lo más alto que han estado desde el 11 de septiembre.
Cuando los movimientos nacionalistas de derecha aumentan en todo el mundo
y ha capturado la presidencia de EE. UU.
Cuando los supremacistas blancos marchan en nuestras calles,
con las antorchas en alto y las capuchas puestas.
Y tengo que contar con el hecho
que mi hijo está creciendo en un país más peligroso para él
que el que me dieron.
Y habrá momentos
cuando no pueda protegerlo
cuando sea visto como un terrorista,
al igual que los negros en EE. UU.
todavía se ven como criminales.
Gente morena, ilegal.
Gente queer y trans, inmoral.
Indígenas, salvaje
Las mujeres y las niñas como propiedad.
Y cuando no pueden ver nuestros cuerpos como el hijo de una madre,
es más fácil prohibirnos,
detenernos,
deportarnos,
encarcelarnos,
sacrifícarnos por la ilusión de seguridad.
(Aplausos)
Yo quería abandonar mi puesto.
Pero hice una promesa,
así que volví a la estación de servicio
donde Balbir Singh Sodhi fue asesinado 15 años.
Puse una vela en el lugar donde murió desangrado.
Su hermano, Rana, se volvió hacia mí
y dijo: "Nada ha cambiado".
Y pregunté,
"¿A quién no hemos tratado de amar todavía?"
Decidimos llamar al asesino a prisión.
El teléfono suena.
Mi corazón late en mis oídos.
Escucho la voz de Frank Roque,
un hombre que una vez dijo:
"Voy a salir y disparar a las cabezas con turbantes.
Deberíamos matar a sus hijos también".
Y cada impulso emocional en mí dice: "No puedo".
Se convierte en un acto de voluntad el preguntar.
"¿Por qué?" Pregunto.
"¿Por qué aceptaste hablar con nosotros?"
Frank dice: "Siento lo que sucedió,
también siento por todas las personas asesinadas el 11 de septiembre".
Él no puede asumir la responsabilidad.
Me enojo para proteger a Rana,
pero Rana todavía tiene preguntas para Frank,
escuchando,
dice:
"Frank, esta es la primera vez que te escucho decir
que sientes pena".
Y Frank:
Frank dice: "Sí.
Siento lo que hice a tu hermano.
Un día cuando vaya al cielo para ser juzgado por Dios,
pediré ver a tu hermano.
Y lo abrazaré.
Y le pediré perdón".
Y Rana dice:
"Ya te perdonamos".
El perdón no es olvidar.
El perdón es liberarse del odio.
Porque cuando estamos libres de odio,
vemos a los que nos lastiman no como monstruos,
sino como personas que están heridas,
que se sienten amenazadas,
que no saben qué hacer con su inseguridad
sino lastimarnos, apretar el gatillo,
o emitir votos,
o aprobar la política que les interesa.
Pero si algunos de nosotros empezamos a preguntarnos sobre ellos,
escuchamos sus historias,
aprendemos que la participación en la opresión tiene un costo.
Los separa de su propia capacidad de amar.
Esta fue mi segunda lección de amor revolucionario.
Amamos a nuestros oponentes cuando cuidamos la herida en ellos.
Cuidar la herida no es sanarlos,
solo ellos pueden hacer eso.
Solo atenderlo nos permite
ver a nuestros oponentes:
al terrorista, al fanático, al demagogo.
Se han radicalizado por culturas y políticas que juntos podemos cambiar.
Vi en retrospectiva todas nuestras campañas,
y me di cuenta de que cada vez que luchábamos contra malos actores,
no cambiamos mucho.
Pero cuando elegimos manejar nuestras espadas y escudos
para luchar contra los malos sistemas,
entonces es cuando vimos el cambio.
He trabajado en campañas
que han librado a cientos de personas de la incomunicación,
han reformado un departamento de policía corrupto,
han cambiado la política federal de crímenes de odio.
La elección de amar a nuestros oponentes es moral y pragmática,
y abre la posibilidad previamente inimaginable
de reconciliación.
Pero recuerden,
tomó 15 años hacer esa llamada telefónica.
Tenía que atender mi propia rabia y dolor primero.
Amar a nuestros oponentes requiere que nos amemos a nosotros mismos.
Gandhi, King, Mandela
enseñaron mucho sobre cómo amar a los demás y a los oponentes.
No hablaron mucho sobre amarnos a nosotros mismos.
Esta es una intervención feminista.
(Aplausos)
Sí.
Porque durante mucho tiempo las mujeres y las mujeres de color
han sido adiestradas a reprimir su ira,
a reprimir su dolor en nombre del amor y el perdón.
Pero cuando reprimimos nuestra ira,
ahí es cuando se convierte en odio dirigido hacia afuera,
pero generalmente dirigido hacia adentro.
Pero la maternidad me ha enseñado que todas nuestras emociones son necesarias.
La alegría es el regalo del amor.
El dolor es el precio del amor.
La ira es la fuerza que lo protege.
Esta fue mi tercera lección de amor revolucionario.
Nos amamos a nosotros mismos
al respirar a través del fuego del dolor
y al negarnos a dejar que se convierta en odio.
Es por eso que creo
que ese amor debe practicarse en las tres direcciones
para ser revolucionario
Amarnos a nosotros mismos nos hace sentir bien,
pero es narcisismo.
(Risas)
Amar solo a nuestros oponentes es autodesprecio.
Amar a los demás es ineficaz.
Aquí es donde muchos de nuestros movimientos viven en este momento.
Necesitamos practicar las tres formas de amor.
Y ¿cómo lo practicamos?
¿Preparados?
Número uno:
para amar a los demás,
no vean extraños.
Podemos entrenar nuestros ojos para mirar a los extraños en la calle,
en el metro, en la pantalla,
y decir en nuestras mentes,
"Hermano,
hermana,
tía,
tío."
Y cuando decimos esto, lo que estamos diciendo es,
"Eres parte de mí, todavía no lo sé".
Elijo preguntarme por ti.
Voy a escuchar tus historias
y agarrar una espada cuando estás en peligro".
Y, número dos:
para amar a nuestros oponentes,
cuiden la herida
¿Pueden ver heridas en los que les lastimaron?
¿Pueden preguntarse incluso sobre ellos?
Y si esta pregunta llena de pánico su cuerpo,
entonces su acto más revolucionario
es preguntarse, escuchar y responder a sus propias necesidades.
Número tres:
para amarnos a nosotros mismos,
respiren y empujen.
Cuando estamos empujando en los incendios en nuestros cuerpos
o los incendios en el mundo,
tenemos que estar respirando juntos,
para poder empujar juntos.
¿Cómo respiran todos los días?
¿Con quién están respirando?
Porque...
cuando los decretos presidenciales y las noticias de violencia
golpean nuestros cuerpos con fuerza,
a veces con menos de un minuto de diferencia,
se siente como morir.
En esos momentos,
mi hijo pone su mano en mi mejilla y dice:
"¿Hora de baile, mami?"
Y bailamos.
En la oscuridad, respiramos y bailamos.
Nuestra familia se convierte en un bolsillo de amor revolucionario.
Nuestra alegría es un acto de resistencia moral.
¿Cómo protegen su alegría todos los días?
Porque con alegría vemos incluso oscuridad con ojos nuevos.
Y entonces la madre en mí pregunta,
¿y si esta oscuridad no es la oscuridad de la tumba?
sino la oscuridad del útero?
¿Qué pasa si nuestro futuro no está muerto,
sino aún esperando nacer?
¿Qué pasa si esta es nuestra gran transición?
Recuerde la sabiduría de la partera.
"Respira", dice ella.
Y entonces,
"empujar."
Porque si no empujamos, moriremos.
Si no respiramos, moriremos.
El amor revolucionario requiere que respiremos y empujemos a través del fuego
con el corazón de un guerrero y los ojos de un santo
para que un día,
un día verán a mi hijo como propio
y lo protegerán cuando yo no esté ahí.
Cuidarán las heridas de los que quieren lastimarlo.
Uds. le enseñarán a amarse a sí mismo,
porque Uds. se aman a sí mismos.
Y le susurrará al oído,
como yo susurro en los suyos,
"Eres valiente."
Eres valiente.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
(Oración Sikh) Waheguru Ji Ka Khalsa,
Waheguru Ji Ki Fateh.
(Aplausos)